the president of Ukraine says Russia's
attacks on his country's power grid have
left four and a half million people in
the dark this war has been going on for
more than eight months and both sides
are trying to gain an advantage on the
battlefield before winter sets in Holly
Williams just spoke to one Ukrainian man
we met at the start of the war when he
volunteered to join the Army trying to
save his country he's seen a lot since
then
and they attacked alcohol we first met
private Andre Rogowski in March just
after Russia invaded he'd quit his job
as a crane operator signed up done his
basic training and was heading to the
front line to fight Vladimir Putin's
invading Army
pure evil exactly
how are you fast forward seven months
and private rogalski is now a hardened
Soldier he took a shrapnel wound in his
leg in May and recovered but he told us
some of his brothers in arms weren't so
lucky I saw
that death I saw combat
I saw
sadness and I saw Joy
he took us to the small town of Visa
capilia occupied by Russians for nearly
six months which he battled to liberate
Nadia's subside told us the Russian
soldiers shot up her car for fun and
looted whatever they wanted she took
shelter in this basement when there was
Heavy fighting she says along with seven
other families some with children
children
next door is what was the local hospital
it's just ruined Nadia says the Russians
stole the medicine and equipment and
turned it into a base
I want to bow to Ukrainian soldiers
Nadia told us I'm proud to see them I'm
one of three people it's not right
they came and take what not belongs to
them
this morning's Holly Williams visit
capilia Ukraine
Holly Williams powerful reporting